I'm in Cleland Wildlife Park in Adelaide
sudden Australia and I'm feeding a
kangaroo
been a minute I'm going to see the Koala
and I'm really excited because koalas
eat eucalyptus and eucalyptus has been
really important in the development of
Australian chemistry
two days ago I was giving a lecture and
I made a terrible mistake I said I was
going to see a koala bear because that's
what we call them in England and I was
told off at once they're koalas they're
not bears so I apologized eucalyptus is
a whole series of different trees in the
same family that grow in Australia and
this is one of them here they're nearly
I think seven or eight hundred different
species but what characterizes most of
them is that if you break off a leaf and
crunch it up you get a very strange
smell from the oil and it was analyzing
this oil which was really one of the
starts of chemistry in Australia boy I'm
just trying to find it there that's a
nicely good boy you can extract quite a
lot of oil out of this leaves and the
oil is quite poisonous so very few
animals eat the leaves of these trees
which means that they're here for the
koalas because the koalas have a
digestive system that will get rid of
the poisons which would kill other
animals so the tree in a way is like
special restaurants for the koalas and
nobody else can eat them analyzing the
oil was quite a challenge and some of
the first chemists isolated a molecule
that's called eucalyptol or sometimes it
has a more technical name of 1/8 Cine
old so while I was here in Australia I
found an article in this magazine about
the first chemist in Australia and very
conveniently for me it has a nice
picture of these molecules and this
molecule here has a variety properties
but the oil itself is an insecticide it
has a nasty smell and presumably the
insects don't like it either my father
used to use eucalyptus oil when he had a
cold and one day and I don't know why he
put it on his hair by mistake and my god
there was a smell could hardly sit in
the car with him so I'm sure the insects
don't like it either and even to this
day you can get eucalyptus oil to buy as
a remedy for yourself here is photos of
old eucalyptus oil but in the shop here
at the Wildlife Center we've saw seen
eucalyptus hand cream
eucalyptus soap even eucalyptus tea I
don't know perhaps you can drink and
keep the insects away I don't know I'm
on across his back just put one hand
across his back his hand across his back
beautiful eucalyptus oil is a mixture of
compounds but the sin oil is the major
component and depending on the species
of eucalyptus tree so you get more or
less and in some species it's really
quite a high percentage of the oil and
that's the ones that they found where
they found it first but now they've
found it in all sorts of them there are
those types of eucalyptus tree which
grow in Western Australia near the city
of Perth where the tree has lots of
different stems which they think the the
wood from those trees could perhaps be
used as a biofuel for aeroplanes and the
company now is trying to make aviation
fuel out of eucalyptus trees but I think
I wouldn't wait to go home till they've
perfected the process but let's come
back to the coal
the Bears because the sorry let's try
that again
let's come back to the koalas and the
koalas eat the leaves but they're very
fussy they only want some leaves and not
others and chemists have done quite a
lot of work to try and decide why they
choose this leaf and not another one and
the answer seems to be that they sense
the amount of a toxic compound or a
series of toxic compounds that are based
on the benzene compound called fluoro
glucan all its fluoro with a pH so it's
not got fluorine in it and this is try
hydroxybenzene and this in itself is
rather an interesting compound because
the industrial manufacture florida Lucan
all goes via TNT the explosive and you
can see these trees are making Florida
Lucca Knoll and they're not explosive so
they must be using a different pathway
and in fact what they do is that they
make the compound via a ring of six
carbon atoms without the benzene
character and then right at the end they
convert this into the benzene whereas
industrial chemists begin with benzene
and work the other way so there's a lot
of clever chemistry that we can learn
from trees in the tree there's no florid
glucan on itself but compounds made from
it and the tree I think has it to
discourage animals from eating it and
even the Koala doesn't like it so it
goes for those leaves where the flora
glucan all levels are low and I expect
that the koalas have evolved so that
they can smell this compound in low
levels so that even if we couldn't smell
it they could tell that there wasn't
much flora gluten or what did you think
I thought holding the
was fantastic I think it will be
probably the best part of my whole trip
though I'm still going to see some
bolognese but these leaves that the
koalas eat don't have much nutritional
value part of the reason they eat it is
to get water because normally unless
they're ill they don't drink water at
all but they have to eat really quite a
lot the one I was holding has to eat
nearly a kilo of leaves a day so and
takes quite a long time so all the koala
but so all the koala does is to sleep
and eat and eat and sleep with about 19
hours of sleep and five hours of eating
so it sounds quite a good life no time
to make chemistry videos if you're a
Karla Baehr except the one we saw you
just call it koala bear again
[Laughter]